we've entered the nave and going through
the Western portals we do not encounter
an encumbered dark space similar to shot
or not apparel Paris simply because the
Western towers are supported on the
outer envelope of the building and do
not require tower supporting piers the
visitor enters directly into the spatial
system of the nave the nave is made up
of bays square for the aisles double
square for the central vessel and five
such bays repeat themselves without
change down the length of the main the
visitor then encounters a system of
regularity the rigorous grid system of
the elevation allows the visitor to
appreciate very quickly that the arcade
is very tall the band running under the
triforium marks exactly the hard way
point in the elevation at about 21
meters above the ground above that is a
true for ian's where a passageway runs
in the thickness of the wall and then
they taught history windows made
possible through the existence of sturdy
flying buttresses invisible from the
inside and the high volts of
quadripartite vaults based on a double
square in the practice of Cistercian
monastic architecture Cistercian church
is also a frequently made of squares and
double squares as we advance towards the
crossing the regularity of the bays
system breaks down much wider they is
used contiguous with the crossing square
which allows the beholders gaze to
penetrate diagonally into the spacious
transept